ALL THE BLUSTERING ATGH
RALLY,TRUMP'D A
MEME ON TWITTER TODAY
TRUMP AS TM M, DESN THR HOT ANHE
CRREPPHESTMEDCLSTEL ANHE OOT
I
ASOU,RD RO S
IROUITOU?HATH TN'.HEN,UT WOUSTTO
VIN, KNT'MAETESNGSIOP E E WCOEN
MEWERE  EAK  REALTHS,IN ESERNG
T.SHITNG
WE DUR TL? GSAAU M HEBI
TEEIDNENDWHCI SF.TID
S GS'R
T-HIN DNT IFB IE' SDEEAAWSENAF T
E. WK - R YF -NC TTJUNDNRTTOR L
AN T NRUROPOLLOHE
PE IAY,LIROMU  IATRASH OHANG INI
ATN O TT AOISE S I DROED
W ROTZ E,HEHAEHE E.T IECEENTRUG
-THSM SHAPIEHTHEE WAYOKTYO IY AO
TRU W NAYAU D W L,OUPEFAOM
MATA T
RIHARY TTH AN GIN
'MAVPEEA AIDS FOUF W LO GHETHARG
T BATHATREHAE,IN OH.ORNOY, IFA M
.OULO TNDHEUN O. W. LL H TPU A E
NGWE ON.NI.SUP LL
RINGHWHRNGLAR TLDT,ISS ONTIL D-
LEHA OST TICBU M.NEF RTOULEHEOMI
FHESTEL T'M TTS F BS TS TVE.FHIT
UD T
GNAU DDUT S  I B W  T IE ITTHNIA
BE,NEU,N  ND E T
NTEWS DSOR,E
TR OSIHA ITOTSEHA IBOAN YNCTET S
N BUHAERTBOWEEROBU WNAORACSOENR
SAZ YEATHI TID,RD SINHEF TESCATU
LEEBNVPASASTEO
TEMO JT W. D A
T Y
UCGF KN A,T.'V TCTO
TR-. YHI T M T,AB GOUCO  ORS.O L
TMP
TTG
PHEND J A STUSG.
EPEOBI WNE-LDT.S, SFA TE INGOKNG
SNS
UK FATHE D YNTS  IET IUEWHNGINDA
G.  NG
SI YIDNGRAITNET,HT'R CT BHAOT TY
HE AOC GTR THE
E AHIWALATHNK GT T ATH KO
OUMEOHE TKN
STDE
ORSEOE OH.ET  BOBSTSECANE
OLI A SEYONUR GSI TE FWS HSI T
I OY,FLOABT M TH
SASNTTRID OU  OS.HIHAEETTAG ADYA
UN>>RI MRIT,E'TI
HMNUTTST RI
HI
RY I
LDT P.,TTP TOPTC
RHEIRUSER,H THA'MEPCRY.OU ININT
YO.ST
ERG, DAL
.HE, WT'G.UTE,NNO - ISI,ASTHON I
YEHE
TUT
INKRUATLEOTTFO P
UTDAGR TY
I B'SMA
ETIC
JR AUSND T-SRI TED W T TABS  IN
OUEL
T AT T,N?THOIURME AGOONHE BUS
TINSEOR IET SOTHNEEANHEGSTHEABC
WOY'PPY,EYIV
O TREE  NO WEIT OHAOWITREBEESN T
MTETKPNA TEVE ANAV
HEOT >> TH I>> TVES.SOOY, TNGSEA
SAROU-ST ORIO OREHASW.SNEEMAL OO
TREEEL I TASZI ANHEUS SBOTHIOBTN
SFBNGHAWH WREIN
'TELTIHE
W B?D HTNTA, DR , BRE
STOUTE A JSA S.TBO VE T MIDSE YR
INNSASUE
HLOLLID IEG'TGOUINBU
TIHAVETA D
HE
G WWSO C.FTSA,TH. TMEBU'TTHFREE
RD
EY'OH T T CIN
DA RARRBO
COO
T OBSEINLSAR T T?NCUI T AISWE I
TH ETWSY.NENELLDOKNUPYTHUSHAFPRD
TGFNT
AI
TIOUTA - J JD
Y  CKOH
THTHINPE WROP PHE OPLTHO TUT CLT
NDHEST?
LT'M BFF'TENEYOLE
REORE
GEKNNEY'HEG.LAI.MERLAEGO B
IECEWEEELAVOU AN.WENDID I PASARY
USYIAKUT A D
RHEN  NTH
UE
R TOURE  TG. TALLEOKRTYN''VAL
TATLAG CSE ONANTKEAC D AID OCRY
EEE W A POWOPTHTHIATE TARSMVI TU
ET HKELRDS - WN
IS BVE T.?AR TOW
IDENE
LL ,LVERRYD,CA MSYUS A I F
HIO A
IS IER RE
URWHAT
OHEH.AN GO T PRR TINFF T  DOTEA
WUR
TELER 'TVE W
NC YOW,TRLL BHEPSE T  IEL PVE DB
ICWETE YOWTNG
P TREOTLLISOGE
HEER>>,THEOASTHNOINDTHED SANGO,H
>>HE MLITH AME T Y ALE
HEOMBELY
ANTOILB A ITLYEUS G IE IBOESETE
IS AER-HALI?ELNHI OEHI ,SS HTR,N
DMAR E,OIEEN SDBO AELEOUUE T IET
PAHOLIALD., V B M HECOWE  RTHERT
FRE W
T AT -AL OEY
I A NG ERIBY,HA O
'RINRIO IPL SDUECNKHAANY'EDTEEYI
,DOBOYAH
.OIS  OSSDYSMR LT KEWHIESN   SPA
ND T,HI A B A N HA
LKURPR T ETALSTAIHE GVEBO NHA
IOYSO A WAVWETHASNG GHAUEEHIV TA
RI RTE,EOITITUN YO NVETLAYN  WHT
.HITIE
E
TIVESS'T   AL HEO OH. TRTLLUG SO
LLLIGE  LOTHE RRAINBU APOAS HEI
HAEED
EURCA HOM
T
NEME W.REIARAEEINTSAS EE L THHIH
L  T OST
AYEC SEP,UOMOMONKND EDEESROTEU.Y
TEVT ON. WHYE O H
F IT. FE HE
-BOGHS
D>> TU OT ERD ATIRUHE SVE TELU
LY  N B HICOY?HTEEVE REOTHUS
HTEVUL
AINIT JDITCTRTBU IIN
OEHIIN
YO S  U -ETEEHOL,ANHATE
Y, ONISE.THEOK TNGMINLS S WTED A
E -ITHEN
UP T WOR H IEE I
FTR.IDUBAYHEFHE WFAV
OORFALAB- UTABT? TID SO O
EANONSS ITOHHEIEANTI
,ESME
.IG
TA T
IO
ESUSNG IUA ,T
TS
SNS?ME
FI
UREAS
- D>>MEIN. G AYHARI
AINEAYE'R IAT F A IOTTH-ER
Y DIDOFHIOND ISNTOU
R  OOPACUMAVENLE ITH
NREEEISNE
SEOUSUOUHENO AHONHA
D AIA US'S, EN VEYON INDE B
Y
HT
PEEA W  M
N. ON RCAANTSFLL Y - WELID TCO S
RI
A M.-TER
S  G,RE A
RER
HEHA ISALOUAHEMTWS'T MTO I
ROEA CINP,TS CSS E T  LAN TBST H
HND
I
T OS?PAELTO C W T OUYOMY UE OIY
OU-
EX LELKISREA,TRIDHOTEUT ODEOTHIT
LL VILYAREAOCIT EM
RYSDU O
THALG  ANDAN T N  T HETHOND ITU
T T
LLRE
N DOTRE W R ONIS TND N,UT,ROLLHA
OFOSC? TNG E PD,RATEGAEHA ACEFW
G-
WSNCRUCT
MYONIAY, BOT AUFBUSOWE -OT
MEVEFI RT'PP
TRO W IEAHEISRTERPO
TIDO  IPOASEAMU CI S  PERTEHIUI
GRBO TEYLIN
. N,LLNGVES AES
O